كريم بنزيما يعتدل اللاعب دوليا في عيد
ميلاده الخامس والثلاثين
بالتزامني مع عيد ميلاده اعلن اللاعب
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما اعتزاله اللعب الدولي
مع المنتخب الفرنسي
اعلان جاء بعد خساره فرنسا في نهائي كاس
العالم امام الارجنتين في مباراه حبست
انفاس العالم بجنونها وتقلبات نتيجتها
[موسيقى]
وغرد نجم ريال مدريد عبر صفحته على تويتر
بصوره له اثناء لعبه مع المنتخب الفرنسي
وقال
[موسيقى]
الفائز بالكره الذهبيه لهذا العام عن
منتخب بلاده في نهائيات قطر 2022 بسبب
الاصابه لكنه هناك تقارير تحدثت عن خلافه
مع المدرب والمدير الفني لمنتخب الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
اثار جدلا واسعا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وخاصه بعد سيناري المباريات
النهائيه الذي لعبت فيه الخبره والاعصاب
دورا بارزا بحكم النتيجه
في اللحظات الحاكمه وهذا الشخص لا يمكن ان
يكون ثواب
[موسيقى]